it wouldn't be remarkable if it wasn't
for the fact that this is a taliban
press conference 20 years ago tv was
banned here anyone caught even watching
was arrested and punished
now in the grand surroundings of the
country's presidential palace in front
of a white taliban flag they effectively
announced the new islamic emirate of
afghanistan
their leadership is trying to convince
the world that they are new taliban
rebranded to play a role in the
international community
we assure the people of kabul that there
will be no excesses against them and
they will live in peace
have given great sacrifices
for the establishment of an islamic
government and they have the right to
implement
sharia islamic government in afghanistan
questions as well from the media and the
first to a female journalist in an open
setting unheard of her question women's
rights what assurances can you give to
women and girls that their rights will
be protected we recognize the rights of
the women which islam gave them
women can work they can go to the school
they work in they can work in schools
they can work in hospitals
we assure the world that there will be
no excesses
against the women
the taliban vow to uphold women's rights
but within the definition of what they
deem to be compatible with sharia law
clearly they're trying to be reassuring
to a skeptical world
but they are ticking important boxes
like observing the sovereign status of
diplomatic missions we assure the entire
world the people of kabul uh
diplomats living in kabul the the world
bodies the ngos all the organizations
that from now on
no one will be threatened and there will
be no access
against anybody
sure enough the now abandoned british
embassy a large wall complex these days
is locked and guarded humvees parked
outside and apparently at least
untouched
across kabul the taliban continue
patrolling the streets in their familiar
pickup trucks they're here to keep order
but they allowed another first
a women's rights rally this is frankly
astonishing mainly because it wasn't
broken up as they chanted slogans like
don't kill women and afghan women exist
this is all in stark contrast to the
chaos in the airport district of the
city as people
inside the repatriation flights are
underway people waiting on the apron to
be loaded onto transporter planes
these are just abandoned weapons the
breakdown of order here is all too clear
there's an arm store that's been simply
abandoned i could just grab an ak if i
wanted one
as the new government takes shape the
men who will lead it arrived in kandahar
from their mission in qatar
the final piece in the jigsaw of the new
regime
stuart ramsey scott news kabul